so SNL did a
sketch and the sketch was like Latinos
trying to sell something whatever and
then the their their punch line was
that's it Oh and it was just like
something something something is 2499
that's it and then Marcelo and Olivia
Rodrigo and what's that Adam Driver and
I think one more girl I forget her name
and uh that's it was the punchline like
they all just go that's it that's it
that's it and I think a lot of people
are like yo that's kind of giannis's
character now and I think Giannis was
very measured in his response to this do
you guys don't know what I'm talking
about I didn't see this I watch I did
not see this but um but yeah it's got to
be frustrating for Giannis yeah and it
it's also like what is going on at SNL
like like you're all comedians we all
know each other we've all come up
together we know this character like
you're intimately involved in comedy if
you're a writer you're putting these
three Comics that are up there In Harm's
Way because they're going to get all the
scrutiny for doing the sketch that is
like you know similar to what Giannis
did that's what jannis said basically
he's like I've been doing this for 20
years there's no way that no one in
there yeah so he had he had this tweet
which was like I thought a good response
D is definitely just saying that how
hold on you said you hadn't heard about
it and then you just said I thought this
was a great response the second you
pulled up the tweet but yeah I just I
skimmed it I'm a skimmer that that b he
has built it why y'all do this why yall
taking all this credit I actually never
this mil say some [__] and you're like
yeah that proves me right no because I'm
always right but I just read the first
line I just read the first line said
it's definitely way of that said it's a
new Ean action it's been around forever
I assume I'm an NYC kid I love everyone
around NYC y
y so don't just fast talk shut you up I
was I was locked in on that one keep
going I can't read my [__] eyes go
Maurice is the one that made that F
funny established a widely similar to
catchphrase like you go girl with Martin
Lawrence are you so crazy it's about how
you said it and why for comedic effect
and purpose no ill will Harvard I'm sure
many younger kids don't know its Origins
now it's gotten so big and it's become a
part of Pop Culture I didn't
intentionally make the catch race
popular the fans decided it was it
officially belongs to everyone out much
love to Marcelo he's cute charismatic
kid who Marissa would defin want to get
Pantha activated
on what a brilliant what a measured
response that I skinmed yeah yeah I mean
brilliant and just so sweet like shout
out to Yannis yeah he tweeted that
handled that very well does he still
handled that way better than he handled
me giving him Co I'll tell you
that I wish he said some [__] like that
when he got Co for a couple days
everyone gets sick what I mean acted up
about a cold this guy you know what I
mean you almost killed him you almost
killed you did almost kill yeah but he
went to Rogan said I did on purpose did
you did you that was racist did you or
did you not that's
racist that's it okay so here's the
question first of all I love what he
said second of all if you're SNL and
you're a comedy institution isn't there
a part of you that's going yo this is
kind of similar to this thing that
jannis made an incredibly popular should
we be wary of this at
all does he still do it yeah yeah like
when he does the character rarely he'll
do the character as shows but like even
if he even if he didn't like I guess
what I'm saying is you know that people
are going to make this
connection is the sketch which isn't
that funny worth the screw
me I'm trying to give them Grace cuz I
can definitely see Marcelo not knowing
he's from Florida right and he's young
he's like 26 so he's probably not going
to know that's it everybody in this area
knows but in Florida you might have just
you know there's no newor Ricans there
you know I don't know if all the writers
on the show like going to get checked
and like everybody's in on it so it's
like somebody would bring I don't blame
Marcelo at all I think it's on the
writers to like have to go through it
that's what I'm trying to think is there
a writer who's I mean if Marcelo is if
Marcelo is aware of the other thing is
just Marcelo is a Latin kid who grew up
around people saying that's it it's part
of his community it's not like owned
bannis so he probably said that's it his
aunt said that's it his sister said
that's it he probably feels ownership of
this phrase that was also popularized by
this kid who's not even Hispanic so
maybe he feels more comfortable for that
and it's not like they're taking jokes
but I do see the similarities where like
he's kind of dressing up as like a
flamboyant like gay guy and maissa was
like a transwoman gay dude kind of thing
where but yeah it's just this like I
don't know like you know that there's
going to be some controversy that comes
with it does that never happen in comedy
you know like hip-hop like people will
use a line from a song and it's almost
like
you're yeah JayZ did it with biggie they
do it all the time and so does that ever
happen in comedy like you kind of repeat
a tag that was so big and it's like ah
this is that's it would have to be so
big that we're all laughing at like
referring to that what did he do get her
done or something no he did like a whole
big joke and he was like H pocket oh
yeah he has I had a comedy I had another
friend of mine finished that joke or
some [__] like that but like it's an
obvious omage to a super famous bit
gotcha yeah yeah or you're making fun of
that com yeah yeah so it's either like
you're biging them up make but it's not
as prevalent and uh yeah it's I don't
know it's so weird dude the sketch that
they did did you guys see the sketch
that SNL did about the uh Dei hearing
the Harvard [__]
I mean it's so bad really and it's it's
not only bad it's like to me it's the
most obvious thing right like with this
di we're talking about when pen and
Harvard and I think MIT came in front of
Congress and the angle that they're
taking is that Congress was
being outlandish that's crazy or Out For
Blood like the angle is that the
congresswoman was being a [__] and then
she was just out for blood and it's like
what's a reasonable thing to be Out For
Blood four yeah it's ALS you I mean
regardless of what side of the issue
you're on that was crazy to have three
institutions of IV leagues being like no
yeah I don't know how to like just
handling it that poorly regardless of
what side you're on I didn't but like
the premise actually kind of sounds more
fun to me like defending the Congress
people yeah but it just has to be super
fun but I also and also it probably
aligns with our actual politic yeah and
that I was trying to think in my brain
we start talking I was like dude SNL
used to be more neutral and I don't know
that it was I think we just didn't we
weren't so like uh biased in our
political comedy it's just we make fun
of all the politicians that's what it is
whatever my politics are all y'all are
getting jokes that's what we're doing
we're just laughing all right guys let's
take a break for a second it's holidays
okay it's holidays and holiday dick need
to be good why does it need to be good
because you're with your family maybe
you're with your wife's family your
girl's family and they need to know that
you're laying it down
they need to hear you they need to hear
the banister they need to hear the bed
backboard slamming against that thin
drywall they got between your room and
uh your girl's cousin's
room simple as that okay you're having
turkey I know you got that tripop fan in
the system you're tired dick probably
slouching not when you chew it up not
when you chew it up chew it out
headboard smack it against the wall
waking up the whole house okay Santa's
here not coming down the chimney coming
in it
Santa's here all the presents we got a
bag full of them all the presents
Santa's here blue CH is
delivering for you same active
ingredients inside Seattle s Viagra but
this is the chuds one that we rock with
simple as that and you're going to get
it for free all you got to do to have
the best dick of your life all you got
to do to have the best dick of your life
and you're going to get it free all you
got to do is pay $5 shipping when you go
to blue.com use the promo code flagrant
that is it you are welcome no more needs
to be said let's get back to the show I
just figured it was that like a lot of
the staff comes from
Harvard they're like all right at the
Harvard Lampoon and like they come from
these iaag schools so they want to
defend the institutions that are baked
into their identity which right now are
being Ragdoll as they should because
they got these goofy [__] that refuse
to just say being anti-semitic is wrong
now it's not even one of these
conversations where it's like if you
want to be a free speech abs solst where
you could say racist things you say
anti-semitic things you could say sexist
things you say homophobic things and the
institution basically is going we want
to have these conversations even though
they're disgusting because maybe
sometimes these disgusting conversations
could lead to somewhere productive I get
that but the re the hypocrisy isn't that
they're allowing this correct it's that
they're protecting certain groups yes
against this free speech and then not
others so there's the hypocrisy they
police free they police speech very like
harshly in some areas and then all of a
sudden here they're letting it go and if
I don't know if men shapir is a free
speech absolutist I kind of assume he is
but if he was one and then he was
complaining about somebody saying
something anti-semitic he'd be equally
corny yes doesn't matter what side of
the issue you're on it's the hypocrisy
that I think most neutral people or and
then I yeah I was like I was talking to
some people who went to like study
universities like recently I didn't
realize
how volatile it's become at the
University level this issue or all like
just general this specific one Dei
really and like oh
yeah and again this is like during BLM
so it's going to be extra but like
students telling teachers to stop
talking about something because it
wasn't their story to tell like a white
teacher talking about a black issue
black students standing up and going hey
you shouldn't speak on this because this
is you're not your story to tell teacher
stops jesz
this like and and and it's and I guess
that there is this like power struggle
that is
existing
within I don't want to say power
struggle with in the univers at the
University level but like there is this
power Dynamic that is at play here where
those that are in power should feel
allegedly in power should feel guilty
about that power position they have so
those that are not in power can level
the playing field by telling them not to
uh use that power in anybody else maybe
even speak on things that they can't be
so there's this ability to kind of
silence and because of the power Dynamic
that created it is white people who are
in power so now white people just shut
up when it comes to these issues right
now this is an educational institution
the people here should be experts yes on
what they're talking about so we're not
hiring them because they're white We're
hiring them because they've studied this
field usually with to the PHD level and
now just telling someone to shut up
regardless of everything that they've
written everything that they studied
simply because of the color of their
skin seems to be the exact problem we're
trying to avoid yeah yeah right and it's
like now if I'm a foreign
Nation I have
succeeded yeah like if I'm a if I'm an
enemy of America I have succeeded I have
infiltrated the universities the most
influential universities and thought
creators on this or in this country and
I have convinced them of a new way of
thinking that will absolutely lead to
division amongst the populace and
resentment this is what Florida should
do you know how they're like trying to
stop teaching about slavery and [__]
they should just be like hey a lot of
our teachers are white can't talk about
it and they're just like sorry we're not
allowed to talk about slavery dude we
got white teachers they can't talk about
that oh so so almost respect the Dei
thing yeah we can't can't talk about
that's a good that's not my Dre too many
white teachers guys yeah we can't talk
about slavery we got to talk about you
know colonialism yeah yeah that's that's
what they can talk about but don't you
want to learn about it from the
experts you yeah you want want to be
like my great grandpa yeah we don't want
to learn how to be a slave we want to
learn how to be a slave owner right like
what was the system yeah tell me how all
the things worked you want to learn
about both maybe you need two maybe you
need like dueling you need like Dre and
Eminem type [__] every class got both
and then they kind of just do you know
what's crazy is kids are getting
hundreds of thousands of dollars into
debt to be taught like this I mean it's
like you're taking on a an essentially a
mortgage yeah yeah to not learn what
wouldn't that be a fun job though to be
like a Dei person like at my college I
knew like the diversity and inclusion
people oh you had it at your school yeah
we had a whole office and what what what
what happened my dream job it was just
always just like a gay black chick and
she would just kind of walk into places
and be like need more blacks i' be like
you get paid for this that's fire that's
what I'm saying that would be my dream
job just to walk into any boardroom be
like and like they would consult for
businesses and [__] and just like walk
into like a real estate group and be
like need more Jews and they would just
like plug in they would just look around
and be like theyve never said that one
set of real sh that's a good point yeah
they go to construction they go to
construction sites like more Jews but
just like just going into a place being
like got to mix it up I feel like I'd be
so good at that I mean that's a real job
a lot of Mexicans at this work site we
got to we got to throw some more people
in more diversity it just seems so funny
that you got to go in just be like H
who's missing I understand the idea
behind it sure well intentioned but I
mean at some point you got to be
reasonable and you also have to 100% you
got to be reasonable and you also have
to understand like how humans relate to
power like if you give humans power we
will abuse it true it's just the nature
of humanity it's very rare that somebody
gets power and is benevolent with it we
get lucky when it happens it's pretty
[__] awesome but like giving somebody
who has you know their entire life been
or feels as if that they've been had
power withdrawn from them and then all
of a sudden giving them the power to
exact change oh that must be
intoxicating you might start walking
into a room and being like not enough
here yeah but I was thinking about that
with term limits with presidents I was
like what if we got someone like should
we have term limits oh my well there's
the argument like if you get someone
that's fire just be like run it back so
this is the argument I think why like
you can in the parliamentary system why
you can just continue running it back
with a president or a prime minister
whatever is because they're just the
leader of that party so they're not I
guess elected the party is elected and
if the party has them at the leader the
party can just continue doing it and
doing it and doing it yeah but I don't
think there were term limits initially
yeah until Roosevelt yeah that's right
yeah but like imagine like Obama just
ran up against Trump again ran it back
three times you know what I'm saying
like all a now it's like my issue with
re-election ISL politicians just try to
get reelected as opposed to doing the
best job so they'll just TR hey these
guys this voting block let's just make
them happy and it's not always the
general population that votes it's the
guys or they'll give me the most money
that can help me get other votes and
sway things in my favor yeah I I get the
point I think one six-year term bro I
got a whole argue with my mom cuz she's
like full she's like a monarchist now
she's like we need a
king your mom is lit she's like we need
a king because if you get a good King
things are awesome and if you get a bad
King you can make a coup you can usurp
him but if you get a good King things
are pretty good but the king is the king
it's not that easy to just have a coup
but she was you know it's easier an
election call her up dude she was she
was putting me in a spin cycle I was in
Whirlwind I by the end of the combo I
was like yo we might need a monarch dude
like having a king might be awesome if
it's a good King Game of Throne [__]
exctly be awesome there's an argument to
I think Jordan Peterson was making a bit
about like uh how the monarchy helps
Great
Britain because not just as like a
tourist employee but like there's a
there's an idea of what it is to be
British so it helps like make national
identity yeah creates like national
identity like this is how you're
supposed to speak this is how you're
supposed to dress this is how you're
supposed to eat
this is a version of what it is to be
British so just everybody kind of like
wraps themselves around that idea and
naturally the different you know towns
have their different accents and their
different cultures Etc but they have an
idea of what it is to be British so it
just helps kind of and also when things
are annoying or bad there's a a group of
people that you can blame for it right
right right MH yeah there's just like a
what is it called like a Whipping Boy or
something yeah you know and um so maybe
there's some value to that I guess in
America that's theid president is like
you don't like how [__] is going you're
like well [__] Biden he's [__] it all
up right like these markets are decided
way before Biden gets into office yeah
maybe they can manipulate them a little
bit like maybe in an election year all
of a sudden mortgage rates are going to
start to go down right which seems
manipulative doesn't it I think that's
about start happening actually they all
no I'm sure they all do it but it is a
little isn't that kind of like yeah okay
the second it's time for you to be
reelected all of the sudden I refi my
mortgage and I got a few more Grand in
my pocket this is PR I'm saying I don't
think we should have any reelection you
could have a longer term fine you got
eight years I don't care but the
reelection I don't I think it's just
skews everything I got you because
you're fighting for reelection instead
of fighting for the public the best of
the what's best for the country yeah let
me if I have one term and then I'm out
I'm going to actually do what I think is
best but if I have two terms what's
going to get me reelected I don't know
what's good what's bad I just need to
know what's going to get me reelected
that's my goal is to get re-elect it's
not J four years isn't necessarily
enough to get much that's what I'm
saying six to eight but then if you do
and they're a shitty ass president now
you sitting here with with for a decade
six is still you want to sit with a
shitty president for we doing it for
three right now we do it for four yeah
we we did it for yeah four years and he
might get four more you know I mean yeah
history even though he seems like a
great guy history is not looking back
very fondly on George Bush Jr's
presidency you got eight
years we came out of it okay yeah it's
one sixy year term
not bad idea about it bro this my maybe
my greatest idea that in investing in
Bitcoin or a king son your boy's
up